Hawkeye started out as a supervillain back
in 1964, but soon switched sides and teamed
up with the Avengers in 1965 — and he’s
been a key player in the Marvel universe ever
since.
From his cameo appearance in 2011's Thor,
to his expanded roles in the Avengers movies
and Captain America: Civil War, Hawkeye is
a fixture of the Marvel Cinematic Universe
these days.
The studio was wise enough to lock up-and-comer
Jeremy Renner into a longterm contract early
on, and he’s become a star in his own right
over the past few years.
So why won't Marvel give Hawkeye a movie?
Fatigue
Renner has been a cog in the Marvel machine
for a while now, but he was famously unhappy
with his role in The Avengers.
The actor made it clear he felt his character
was short-changed, and considering he spent
most of the movie mindlessly brainwashed and
working for Loki, it's hard to argue.
He told Hero Complex:
“At the end of the day, 90 percent of the
movie, I’m not the character I signed on
to play.
I’m literally in there for two minutes,
and then all of a sudden…”
Thankfully, he's warmed up to his superhero
role since then.
During a Reddit AMA while promoting Avengers:
Age of Ultron, he said he would “be game”
if Marvel ever wanted to make a superhero
movie.
But, he’ll be six movies in after the next
two Avengers films.
He may be game for now, but it's hard not
to wonder how long he’ll be interested in
playing Marvel’s man who can’t miss.
"I've done the whole mind control thing...not
a fan."
But let's assume Marvel starts to look at
Hawkeye's comic book history for inspiration.
Well, they may not find much…
Short on stories
Hawkeye has been around the comic scene for
decades, but he doesn’t really have a lot
of iconic stories that would translate well
to the big screen.
There’s a reason fans have been begging
for a Black Widow movie — the super spy
has a mysterious backstory well worth exploring.
The same goes for fellow heroes like The Winter
Soldier, Hulk, and Black Panther.
But Age of Ultron already filled in a lot
of the gaps in Hawkeye’s story.
When he’s not off being a hero, he lives
a quiet life married to Linda Cardellini and
playing with his adorable kids.
Hawkeye is just a regular guy in the MCU.
While that’s part of his appeal, it’s
hard to make a $100 million dollar blockbuster
about an average guy.
Speaking of which…
The Fraction Factor
Writer Matt Fraction’s 2012 Hawkeye series
was one of the most acclaimed comics Marvel
has published in years.
But that doesn’t mean it’d be a good fit
on the big screen.
The comic was a hit because it pretty much
ignored the fact that Hawkeye is a superhero,
and instead focused on his regular life in
a New York City apartment building.
Hawkeye hung around with Kate Bishop, a younger
hero who also goes by the name Hawkeye, and
faced off with a group of Russian gangsters.
It was almost the Seinfeld of comic books.
"Well after ordering, Mr. Seinfeld and Mr.
Costanza debated on whether or not Iron Man
wore some sort of undergarment between his
skin and his iron suit."
"Uh huh."
"And I still say he's naked under there!"
"Oh that makes a lot of sense."
"Ah shut up!"
The series was arguably Hawkeye's best outing
in comic books, so fans might think it'd be
the right inspiration for a movie.
It even won a ton of awards, and was a crazy
fun story — but it didn’t exactly have
the makings of a Hollywood blockbuster.
Though, it would make one heck of a good Netflix
TV series.
Just sayin’.
Packed schedule
You’ll hear this one pretty much anytime
you talk about Marvel movies.
They make a lot of them, and there are plenty
more on the way.
The studio has released more than a dozen
films, with around half a dozen more already
in development.
You already have Guardians of the Galaxy Volume
2, Thor: Ragnarok, Black Panther, Captain
Marvel and the next two Avengers films on
the way.
And that’s just naming a few.
Put simply, there are lots of options on the
table, and Hawkeye has already been in his
fair share of movies.
Low-power, high stakes
No offense to all the archer heroes in the
Marvel and DC universes, but Hawkeye is basically
a guy fighting aliens and giant robots with
a stick and a string.
Hawkeye said it himself.
"Ok look, the city is flying, we're fighting
an army of robots...and I have a bow and arrow.
None of this makes sense."
But Iron Man does make sense because he has
cool, high-tech armor.
Thor makes sense because he flies around the
universe bashing bad guys with a magic hammer.
But shooting arrows?
It’s cool, sure, but it's not on the same
level.
"Keep up old man!"
"Nobody would know...nobody."
There's a reason DC decided to turn Green
Arrow into a TV series.
It seems that skill set is just better suited
for adventures on the small screen.
Team-up
Clint Barton was the heart and soul of the
Avengers in Age of Ultron, and that’s because
he just works really well on a team.
Most of his best moments in the MCU are when
he’s teamed up with other heroes, and he’s
a character who works best when he has someone
to play off of.
He’s had a lot of interesting story arcs
in the comics over the years, but most of
them are tied to larger Avengers stories.
He’s died.
He’s come back to life.
He’s even hung up his bow and arrow to be
a ninja for a while — like you do.
But, all of those stories were connected to
the Avengers.
Age of Ultron was pretty much Hawkeye at his
best, and that’s because it gave fans just
enough to leave them wanting more, as opposed
to two full hours of pure, unfiltered Hawkeye.
So what about Kate?
Marvel doesn’t seem to be afraid of trying
out new characters, so why not give the other
arrow-person a shot?
If Marvel really wanted to get creative, it
could bench Barton and introduce that other
Hawkeye: Kate Bishop.
Kate was introduced in 2005 in Marvel Comics'
Young Avengers comics series, and took up
the name Hawkeye in 2006.
Over the past decade, she's become a close
friend to Barton, and is arguably the better
archer.
Nowadays in the comics, she’s kicking around
California to work as a hard-boiled private
eye.
So maybe she should get a movie, right?
But there's a problem.
Outside of comic readers, she isn't a very
well-known character at all.
Considering we're still waiting on Miles Morales
Spider-Man to get his own live-action movie,
Kate seems like a long shot too.
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel.
Plus check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love too!